[Musik]
frohe Weihnachten mein Schatz auf unser
erstes Weihnachtsfest im schönen Bayern
oder wie man hier sagt BR ach ja das
Bayern irgendwie ist hier ganz anders
als in Kölle aber fein hast sie gekocht
Brust mein Schatz schworbm Obi du kannst
ja schon richtig beayisch ja klar man
muss sich doch hier auch ein bisschen
anpassen
ne das denn am Heiligen
Abend ja hör mal das gibt es ja
nicht ja Mensch Josef was verschlägt
dich denn hierher du alte Hütte wir es
nur immer wieder schaffst dass du alles
aber auch absolut alles falsch Mast
Schatz wer ist das ja das ist der Josef
der hilft mir in Bayern mit der
Integration das ist eine suarbeit und
wer bist du ich ich bin wie
die Wiebke aha bist du aus Köln ja
sicher das Josef darf ich dir ein Glas
Champagner anbieten ach halt nein ich
weiß schon wir haben natürlich auch Bier
aber kein Kölsch das habe ich schon
gelernt von dir ne wir haben Weizenbier
wir haben starkes Bier und wir haben
maybock er lernt es nicht er lernt ist
einfach nicht an Weihnachten gibt's in
Bayern ein Glühwein Glühwein ach das
wusste ich nicht ach ja das haben ich
schon gehört da gibt es ganz tolle
Rezepte mit biorotwein bioor und ganz
seltenen zeilonzimt genau ganz seltenen
zeilonzimt da geht man bei uns zum al
kauft man 2 l Flaschen und dann W
aufgocht und
fertigieß hab jetzt pass auf so jetzt s
wie das
geh
und und bittte
schön er haupzeich schon verbrennt
glühin kann man sehr gut abkühlen mit
Schnaps jetzt müs es
gehen und ja jetzt sag was gibt's den
bei euch zum Essen he ich habe einen
leckeren cocovin zubereitet ich liebe
Cocoa
kocoa Cocoa ihr s rot saufel nicht
[Musik]
fressen so und überhaupt gibt's in
Bayern am Heiligen Abend gibt's Würstel
ein kartoffelsalot und sonst
nich so wirstelh wir Kartoffel sal
Glühwein habmer schnapsmer zu einem
perfekten Heiligabend F jetzt eigentlich
bloß nch ein saftiger
Streit aber wir streiten nicht was h
Streit nicht überhaupt nicht ja das King
wir schon pass auf er sag du einfach
einm was dir bei ihrer total auf dem
Sack
geht bei meiner Wiebke nichts sie ist
perfekt wo ist mein Kübelchen
ma bei dir weiter s mal einfach was du
bei total zum kotzen findest was ich ich
we nicht da gibt es nichts Josef wir wir
lieben uns außer
D Meinung hat ich habe keine eigene
Meinung das ist doch nicht Wahr oder
Josef doch und dass du dich nicht
durchsetzen kannst und immer alle das
machst was die anderen dir sagen ja also
das liegt vielleicht auch daran weiles
nur immer nach deinem Willen gehen muss
und du mich nur rum kommandierst was ich
kommandiere dich rum bah du bist wie
deine Mutter Gott sei Dank sind wir hier
in Bayern da findet die alte blöde
Schachtel ja nicht hin lass meine Mutter
aus dem Spiel und stell dir vor ich
hätte den letzten Satz ein bisschen
leiser gesagt du elender
Waschlappen ja also das geht doch und
nicht vergessen immer schön fleißig
Schnaps nachschütten
so und jetztzeich und ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen Heiligen Abend du
bist eine Null ein
Weichei du kannst nichts du bist nichts
und du wirst auch nichts und du bist ein
[Musik]
Drache Weihnachten in Bayern da gibt's
auf der ganzen we n schönes und die Z
drin die GL ich auf guten Weg
[Musik]
[Applaus]